Welcome to Henderson Hills.
We are disciple makers, anchored in truth, compelled
by love, and desperately dependent on the Lord.
We are generous with what God has given us
and we share life giving help with those around us.
Our mission is to equip one another to love Jesus.
And lip syn, we are glad you're here.
Good evening. We're gonna try that one more time.
This is a crowd participation moment
and I get to go as long as I want to until you participate.
Good evening. Good evening.
Ah, I see you guys catch on so quick.
Uh, this is going to be a great night.
We're gonna have a family choir in just a minute.
Can I have a big round of applause? Yeah. Yeah.
And we also have drama and our speaker Richard Ross is back.
And of course our, our praise and worship leaders.
It's gonna be a great night.
But lemme tell you what we're going to conclude with.
We'll be concluding with a time of family commitment.
And what does that mean? That means that, uh,
we wanna be more than just about the talk
about family discipleship.
We wanna be in prayer for one another.
We wanna be encouraging one another.
We want to, uh, want this to be kind of our culture.
It's who we are. And so, uh, be praying about that
because you do have a part in this service.
Uh, we would love for you to sing with us when we sing.
We'd love you to clap with us when we clap.
But more than anything else, we want you to commune
with the Lord because we are here to reclaim the home
as the space for spiritual influence.
And uh, it's not, it's not a top down thing.
It's not a hierarchy where like dad's the boss
or mom's the boss and everybody listens to her.
Speaker, him speak.
This is, uh, we are learning together how
to come into the presence of God through his word
and through the things that he's given us to seek him.
And so it'll be a process
and none of us, none of us are that good at it.
And we have an enemy that would like for us
to be real bad at it.
But tonight, we refuse that enemy
and we join forces with a living God.
And so we're glad that you're here.
Um, I'm gonna start with a prayer
and then we're gonna sing together.
Father, thank you for these families.
Thank you for the parents
and kids that have decided to spend,
uh, this evening with us.
Or do we wanna do more than have an event.
We want to have a, a moment, Lord, with you where we're able
to dedicate ourselves
and our families to you getting closer to you
and being stronger for you, uh, for your glory.
And uh, Lord, we thank you for this morning.
We thank you Lord, that we enthroned you with our praise,
that uh, we exalted you as our monarch, as our king.
And we want to continue that right now.
And it's in Jesus and we pray. Amen. Let's stand together.
Alright? We're gonna enjoy worshiping the Lord together
tonight in
the on the mountain.
Lord soul
now
is, it's more
as I I to,
I want you guys to sing this out.
Sing these truth about who God is.
Let's this Him praise
you, sovereign praise you, reign, you rose
and great grace.
You faithful grace. You true grace.
There's nobody greater than you.
You sovereign grace you, you
and defeated grace.
You true. And
be
how inside.
And God
inside
we worship God.
Who we God, who we
God, who we worship God.
He opened the he
the
beg.
We were
we.
The,
the,
the.
Amen. I'm gonna pray for us. Uh, Jesus.
Um, we want to give you, um, all of the glory
and all of the honor and the praise, um, this evening
as we, um, we just commit this time to you, to um,
hear from your word
and to, um, commit time to, um, uh, caring
for and discipling intentionally, uh, through the gospel,
uh, our families.
Lord, uh, would you, um,
would you move in a special
and an intentional way this evening as we do that?
Lord, uh, we love you and we pray this in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen. You may be seated.
Okay guys, I need you guys to all stop your performances
and come sit at the table.
Come on guys. We want to talk about something
that's bigger than your hobbies.
Bigger than all your talents,
Bigger than a lead role, bigger
Than a home. Run
Bigger than my aura.
Okay guys, that is all fun.
But nothing lasts longer than your relationship with Jesus.
Life is messy, but God loves us through it.
I mean, I forget to pray sometimes,
or I yell at my brothers. That's
Okay. Penny loving God
isn't about perfection.
It's about trusting him with your whole life
and pointing others to Jesus.
So helping people
and following God is greater than a home run.
So my skills just gifts.
Exactly. Gifts to share, but not badges of honor.
Fine. But can I still sing loudly in the car?
Of course, penny, your talents are wonderful.
Just remember who you're glorifying.
Oh, so if my heart's in the right place,
then I'm honoring God.
Yes. So we use our talents to draw attention to God
and not ourselves.
Talent. I love this church.
I love a talented church.
All of you were brilliant to come here to be a part
of this community of faith.
But in addition to that, I would have to say, those of you
that are actively parenting these days,
what an absolutely wonderful church
to be rearing children in.
I may move my membership from the nursing home to here.
I love what you
and God have created in this particular place.
What if you know this is a participation service?
What if I said, okay, we're gonna do a big participation.
Now this would be interesting.
There's so many of you, I don't think logistically
that this would work,
but I do want you to use your imagination.
What if right now in the service, I ask everyone
to stand to their feet?
And strangely, what if I invited everyone of every age
to come and pack this front area right here?
Once again, I don't think we would fit.
But if we could fit,
and you did come to the front, what if I had given
positions that I wanted groups to stay in?
I think most of you, you know, you would try to cooperate.
Most of you would try to stand where you're supposed to.
What if this had been the plan?
What if I had said everybody up, everybody walked
to the front and I want to create one group right here.
And if you choose this group, you will be saying,
I'm on my way toward God.
Somebody is out there and I'm trying to figure this out.
Somebody invited me to come tonight. I thought a church.
Well that's a good place to find answers.
So I'm here tonight to say I'm on my way toward God.
Now, if we really did the demonstration
and if we really had a group here, I think all
of you would be thrilled to death.
Praise God, appreciate their honesty.
But even though you'd be happy about this group,
the vast majority of you would say, yeah,
but that's not exactly where I should stand.
Maybe a bunch of you would say, I ought
to stand right here in front of the preacher,
and by standing here I will be saying, well,
there was a time in my life I was on my way toward God.
Finally, somebody explained I could know God
through his son Jesus.
Christ's death on the cross. I received that.
But the reason I'm standing here
and not some other places is even though I know Jesus
these days, really the most important person in my world
would be me.
Now. Now by that I mean, you know, during the week,
just trying to get by my crazy kids, my finances, my health,
you know, just the things that make up life.
I would have to say that's probably on my mind
most of the time.
Now I do pray, in fact, I don't even know
how these people get by if you can't tell
Jesus your troubles.
But you know, even when I'm telling him my troubles,
really my preoccupation is with me.
Now, the group that ought to be right here,
very humble people would never take credit for any of this.
But a person standing here might say,
there was a time I was on my way toward God.
Finally somebody explained I could know him through Christ.
And since I came to know him, I cannot take credit
for anything in my Christian life.
It is only the work of God.
But somehow by his grace tonight, I would have
to say the preoccupation of my life is Jesus.
Now I have the same problems as everybody else.
Oh my goodness, I could tell you my troubles.
But you know, even in my tough times,
really what's on my mind is, oh, I wonder
how Jesus will reveal himself through this.
Oh, I wonder how he will bring his kingdom on earth
through this same thing from our family.
I mean, we might be sitting on the couch
and we're saying, boy, this is tough.
This is heart. I wonder what Jesus will do
to receive glory through this.
So even for my family, the preoccupation
of our lives is Jesus
lost, convert
and to use Jesus's favorite name for these people, disciple,
lost, convert, disciple.
Did you know we have some really great research
that tells us what happens to kids after they leave home.
The research says if I grow up, you know, 18 years
in the home and nobody knows Jesus in that house,
statistically speaking, the odds are that I will leave
that home and I will spend my entire adult life
spiritually lost.
Now, you and I both know there are some exceptions.
In fact, several of you tonight
are the exception you would say, I grew up in a home, nobody
of faith in that house by a miracle of God,
I met him in adulthood.
Absolutely exceptions exist,
but there's not very many of them.
That same research says is,
if I grow up 18 years and my mom
and dad are disciples, not perfect of course,
but in general, my mom
and dad live with Jesus front and center.
He's a topic of conversation in our house.
I watch them make decisions under him.
If I watch that for 18 years, statistically speaking,
I will grow up and be an adult disciple.
Now again, there are a few exceptions.
You can grow up with two disciple parents
and by a strong act of your will, you can reject all of that
and live like the devil.
Yes. But again, the exceptions
are few and far between.
Basically lost homes, create lost adults,
disciple homes create disciple adults,
convert homes, produce young adults
that tend to live their adult lives
as if they're lost.
Now I'm not talking about losing your salvation,
I'm really talking about lifestyle.
Let, let me show you how this works.
Let's just say I'm a kid.
If I grow up in a home, you know, 18 years
and we go down to the church on Sunday,
at least most Sundays, and we fit in just fine.
We know how to say the words, you know, we do fine.
But when we get home, you know, Monday through Saturday,
that church business doesn't seem to come up very much.
It just seems like all the conversation in our house is
about cheerleading and travel ball and SAT scores
and scholarships and a hundred other things.
The dissonance, the dissonance between
that Sunday morning profession
and what I can tell is really most important in our home.
That dissonance, it fries my wiring so much so
that when I go off to the big university,
I don't have enough faith to hold me.
Any campus minister will tell you
when those freshmen walk on campus, really in only two
or three weeks, they are already starting
to behave like the law students.
Perhaps one of the most important sentences of this
entire evening will be the
next sentence.
If you're a parent, the future of your children
hinges primarily on the spiritual condition
of your heart.
The future of your children hinges primarily on the
spiritual condition of your heart.
Now let's see what that kind
of spiritual life might look like in the home.
Time to sit down, provide steady.
You all are going to love tonight's reading.
It has, it's short, it's powerful,
and it has a great question.
I bookmark this chapter this morning.
I love when Jesus teaches in parables.
Yay. Can't wait to decode spiritual mysteries while try,
my brother tries to body slam me.
I'm coming. Just one more swing.
Boone family discipleship now or no cages tomorrow.
Alright, but can we just read fast?
Because Jesus knew people had stuff to do.
Hey Susie, I need you to come sit down.
Okay, everybody listen up. Eyes over here.
We're gonna read from Luke 15, uh,
the Parable of the lost Sheep.
Oh wow. Never heard that one before.
Does it have a twist ending?
Six, seven. Okay. Okay. Everyone needs to listen up.
Okay. Uh, here we go.
So pose one of you has a hundred
sheep and loses one of them.
Does he leave the 99 in the open country and go
after the lost sheep until he finds it?
I'm the last sheep?
That's actually a great metaphor. Boon.
Yeah. If the lost sheep was annoying
and didn't take showers,
I'm the shepherd. I
Found her.
Get Boone. Her neck is in a sheep handle.
Boone, we're not wrestling right now.
Okay? Okay, let's finish this.
And when he finds it,
he joyfully puts it on his shoulders and goes home.
See Boone joyfully. Not like WWE.
Honestly, I don't see why the
shepherd believed the nine, nine sheep.
It shows how much God values even one lost person.
Like even when we're all being crazy,
he's still looking for us.
Hmm. So God would come
after me even if I ditched the group to go play baseball.
Exactly. I mean, that's kind of cool, I guess.
I guess they learned something.
I mean, it's more than I thought they'd get out of it.
Mother, are we dismissed
Next time? Can we do
revelation?
My hand?
Do conversations like that matter? Absolutely. They matter.
Conversations about Jesus, about scripture matter.
Just a few moments ago, I said, the future
of your children hinges primarily on the spiritual
condition of your heart.
And conversations like that is part of the way
that you show kids what's in your heart?
Now, when I say mom
and dad are the biggest influence, somebody might protest.
Somebody might say, brother Richard, you're from Texas.
You're, you're not from around here.
You don't really know about this church.
You don't understand.
We have an absolutely wonderful children's ministry here.
We have a superb youth ministry here. And you do.
I mean, it's well known away from here and that does matter.
I'll talk about that later. But mom and dad, listen to me.
What you cannot do is assume,
my primary responsibility was
to get my family in a good church
and just hope those good people at the church house will
somehow make my kids religious.
This is not dry cleaning.
You do not drop off children
and then hope to pick them up clean and press later on.
The research says, and scripture says, mom
and dad are by far in the way,
the strongest influence spiritually on their children.
Now I wanna take you back to our opening, uh, demonstration.
If we really had done that thing
and if people really had come forward
and you would've found yourself standing here,
I do wanna say, as wonderful
as this evening is dealing with lots
of different subjects for you.
There is nothing going on here tonight.
More important than you deciding.
I think I would like to know Jesus as my savior.
I would like to have a relationship with him.
I would like for him to permeate all my relationships,
including my family for you.
You listen for his voice.
That is your agenda for this evening.
But again, I think the great majority of you are saying,
I know the Lord.
The question for me tonight is, well, am I a convert
or am I a disciple?
It's an interesting question.
Now, in 2025, we have lots of meters,
but we don't have a meter we can poke you with
that says convert or disciple.
We don't have one of those. So all I can do is
ask you some questions.
Mom and dad, go deep inside yourself
and ask yourself a very important question,
what matters to you most about your children?
What goal for your children stands above all others?
I wonder if there's someone tonight
that would say, brother Richard.
Actually what I'm working on the hardest is I want my kids
to succeed at whatever they take on whatever
they get interested in.
I'm trying to give them a leg up.
I'm trying to support them.
I want my kids to succeed in life.
But others of you might say, well, that's nice,
but it's not most important.
Really what I'm working on is I want my kids
to be reasonably happy as they grow up.
I hear about these college students,
these young adults taking their lives.
That's terrible. I don't want my kids part of that,
so I want them to be reasonably happy in life.
Others of you might say, both of you have missed it.
The most important thing is I want my kids to be moral.
I want them to be upright.
I mean, people are doing crazy things out there
and I don't want my kids becoming part of that.
So I'm working on that every day.
Now those are nice things,
but you would find this interesting when we do quality
research and we ask middle class
atheists who have children at home,
what is your primary goal in rearing your children?
Those middle class atheists will either answer success,
happiness, or morality.
If we in the church, if we the people of God say, well,
my goals are happiness, success,
and morality, actually we have the same goals as the people
who think there is no God.
Would you say, I'm a disciple, I'm a mom, I'm a dad.
I'm a single adult that cares about other children.
Would you say I am a disciple?
One way you can detect that is first for yourself,
would you say, I live, my primary goal in living is
for the glory of God.
And consequently, the highest goal I have
for my children is I want to see them
live their complete lives for the glory of God.
Is that true for you? I wanna give you three
challenges, and I want to help you
understand all three of these.
And actually now these challenges are
for the complete church for everyone,
grade schoolers, teenagers, and adults.
My first challenge to you is you be awakened
to the greatness of Christ.
You say, brother Richard, that sounds a lot
like your sermon this morning.
Well, it is like my sermon this morning
because that is the first step
in creating spiritually alive homes.
Let me just ask you a question tonight
that I didn't ask you this morning.
Believer of any age, is it possible
that you have lost your first
love in Jesus?
Many of you familiar with Revelation two, two through four.
Jesus was speaking
and he said, you have done some good things,
but you have lost your first love.
Believe. Let me ask you a question.
Can you go back to an earlier time in your life?
Can you go back to a time
when you would say Jesus was more real to me?
Then I walked more closely with him, then
I was more alive in him.
Then maybe for someone here tonight, you would say, oh,
I was in a Christian youth group.
Oh my goodness, we were so close.
Or maybe for somebody else it was a collegiate ministry
and you would say, man, we were singing
and worshiping late in the night.
I, oh, in my college days, I was so close to him.
Or maybe, maybe you were in a church
that had some wonderful young couples
and y'all were just growing in Christ.
I'm just asking everybody,
would you say there was a time in your life you were closer
to Jesus than you are tonight?
If so, may I just invite you to come back
to your first love.
If you come back to Jesus as your first love,
that is gonna saturate, that's going to permeate
not only parenting,
but any other relationships that you have.
The second challenge I want to give you is this.
Be transparent about your awakening.
Transparent. Now let me just say this to parents.
Parents, some of you are private people. I understand that.
And there's nothing wrong with having a a personality
where you're just a little bit more inside yourself.
That's okay. But you do have to be careful
because you could experience a rebirth.
You could experience a new first love in Jesus
and yet be so private that nobody knows about it.
I wanna challenge all of you, whatever you consider home,
whatever that is for you, talk about Jesus
in that place.
Not just religion, not just the church,
not just Christianity, but talk about Jesus.
And if you've got children in the house,
my suggestion would be when you talk about Jesus,
let there be a sparkle in your eye.
Let there be a sound of your voice that sounds like
this is a being I adore and I love with all of my heart.
I also want to challenge you as a way
to let the kids know what's going on inside you.
Pray with your family.
I think saying grace over mealtime is perfectly fine.
I think it's a wonderful custom,
but that's not what I'm talking about.
Beyond mealtime.
I believe every Christian family ought
to pray together as a family.
We might have some wrestling involved.
We might have some creative comments involved.
It doesn't matter. You're talking to Jesus as a family
and closely related.
I'm challenging you to read the Bible as a family.
It doesn't have to be a lecture, it doesn't have
to be a 30 minute sermon.
It's just the fact that your family had the word of God open
and kids grow up remembering, oh yeah,
it was real at my house.
We actually read the Bible as a family.
Let that be part of their heritage.
Show your delight in Jesus and his kingdom
and that will affect the DNA of your children.
Third partner with your church
to see your children walk in faith, a lifetime partner
with your church to see your children walk in
faith a lifetime.
I think most of you know the statistics, the kids
that grow up in church, actually those
that are here tonight, the children that grow up in church
at 18 or 19 or 20, about half stay in the church
and about half walk away from the church.
I'm not talking about the pagan masses
in the in the community.
I'm talking about church kids.
I hope it matters to you which half your children end up in.
And I wanna say to you, partnering with your church is part
of the way you get kids
that walk in faith the rest of their lives.
Parents, you are in first position. Nothing can change that.
You are gonna have more influence than anything or anybody,
but you can certainly appreciate a church coming
alongside you and supporting you in the process.
This vision that God has given Pastor Phil, it, it is a way
for mom and dad to take the lead,
but the church to come right in behind you saying,
we're gonna do everything we can to stand with you
as a family, to see your kids walk in faith for a lifetime.
Mom and dad, if you figure this out, did you know it changes
how you listen to announcements?
Does that sound strange?
Somebody comes up here on Sunday morning
and makes an announcement or runs some video
and it's about a family this or a family that.
Or here we're gonna pull a family
and you, you say, oh, that, that looks good.
That goes in my phone.
And you get that phone out
and you're kind of chuckling to yourself
and you're thinking, you know, six months ago,
my heart was a little spiritually cold, stuff like that.
I didn't pay any attention to that at all. But I do now.
Why? Because I've had an awakening in my life
and now I'm interested in anything this church is gonna do
to help my family grow spiritually.
But of course, for this church to be a help
to you, you have to be here.
What do you do when you have this exciting opportunity
to have a child travel balls six straight Sunday mornings?
And you're thinking, well, that's exciting,
but man, six Sunday mornings of worship and Bible study.
That kind of seems important. What am I to do?
What do you do when you get two flyers
and you discover in those two flyers that cheerleading camp
and the youth mission trip are the same dates?
How do you decide you're doing a little
bit better financially?
You've got a little bit of wiggle room
and you're thinking, hmm,
more getaway Weekends for my family.
That might be fun, but gosh,
it seems like maybe being faithful
to the church could be important.
What am I to do? I'm not standing here tonight to tell you
what your decisions ought to be,
but I am telling you tonight that those are the kinds
of decisions that you walk straight up to the throne
of heaven and you say, king Jesus, whatever you tell me
to do, that is what I'm going to do
because I live for you alone.
I mentioned Clayton this morning, my only living child,
and I mentioned to you that he got sick
before he got sick, though
he was going on international mission trips
and any group that wanted to go somewhere,
his tendency would just be to jump on the plane.
But for some strange reason, he had a proclivity to go
to those places that are dangerous, places
where they can cut your head off for your faith.
I was out at DFW airport more than once, looking down
that concourse just to make sure that my son had made it on
that particular flight home.
Clayton is better than he was in bed for 10 years.
He's improving. Let me tell you what's about to happen.
This is not supposition. I mean, it could be this week.
What's about to happen is Clayton is going to improve enough
that he's gonna come to me
and he's gonna say, Hey dad, there's a group going
to a certain certain place.
I feel like I'm well enough. I'm gonna go with them.
What am I supposed to say in that moment?
Am I supposed to say, would you please
stay here where it's safe?
Would you please stay here
and see if we can find enough health for you to get married
and have grandchildren?
For me, am I supposed to say, Clayton, could you stay here?
I'm I'm not young and I would love for you to be close by.
When I'm in hospice, what am I supposed
to say, my friend?
I am not gonna stop my son from going even
to a dangerous place, even if his body comes home in a box.
I'm not stopping him. Why?
There's a logical reason why I would not stop him.
Clayton Allen.
Ross is on earth for the glory of God.
That is why he exists.
Therefore, if he exists for the glory of God,
and in this particular instance, Jesus is glorified
by the death of a martyr in a mission field,
how can Dad say anything different from go Now tonight,
Clayton and Richard are really not the issue tonight.
The issue is every one of these children, every one
of these teenagers, they are all on earth
for the glory of God.
Therefore, parents,
there is no part of parenting
that is more important than you parenting in those
specific ways where you are making it most likely
that your sons
and daughters will live all of their adult lives
for the glory of God.
Would you just bow your heads, bow your heads,
Lord Jesus, I know
this room is filled with people that love you
and want to see your kingdom.
Come on this earth serve.
We've got precious grandparents, precious single adults,
all kinds of people that want to see the next generation
run hard after you.
Lord Jesus, would you teach us from your word?
Would you teach us by the power of the Holy Spirit,
how we join you in lifting the eyes of preschoolers
and grade schoolers and teenagers to the glory of Jesus?
Would you give moms and dads such a love
and a passion for you that it would just splash
all over those in their homes?
Lord Jesus, we don't want to lose a one
to the church in the Christian life.
We don't wanna lose half. We don't wanna lose one.
Lord Jesus, I'm praying blessings.
I'm praying favor on this church
as it launches out in this brand new direction
to come alongside families,
to see a generation change the world for your glory.
And it is to that end that we dedicate ourselves tonight.
Amen.
Can we thank, uh, Dr. Richard Ross?
Thank you. He'll be, he'll be coming again to help us
through an exercise that I think you're gonna
find just transformative.
Uh, but before he does that, if you're not sitting
with your parents, this is gonna be
really important that you are.
So if you're sitting away from your parents,
I'm gonna give you opportunities and,
and permission to stand up right now
and just make your way to your parents.
And, uh, and then I wanna say something else.
Uh, this booklet right here, we've prepared 500 of them,
so there's enough for everybody.
This is kind of our, um, operator's manual
for Family Discipleship.
Uh, family Discipleship will not be a series
of events like the one you're experiencing tonight.
Family Discipleship occurs primarily off campus
with no staff persons involved.
And so, uh, if you don't know what that means,
we'll have some training,
we'll have some encouragement along the way, um,
but, uh, it's, it's going to be trial and error.
What we've discovered about family ministry is
that there's no cookie cutter approach.
Some of you have preschoolers, some
of you have elementary schools, some of you have pre-teens,
some of you have teens, some of you have, uh, grown parents.
I'm, I'm, I mean, my, my kids are here
with their kids, so I'm a grandparent.
So there's no cookie cutter simple way
to tell you how to do this.
But, uh, like, uh, Richard Ross said is
that you become a disciple and you glorify God in your life.
And the spiritual conversations just come naturally.
We'll train you how to do this, but, um,
but it, it's going to require a commitment.
And that's why we enter now into this commitment service.
I wanna say something really quickly to grandparents.
Um, I'm sorry that your kids aren't, uh,
elementary school anymore,
but the goal is to grow them up and to send them off.
Uh, it's not an easy thing to do when you send them off.
Um, somebody I'm very close to, uh,
just dropped their daughter off to, uh, OU last year.
And, uh, it was not easy for her.
In fact, I couldn't really mention it without tears.
So it's not an easy thing. But, but here's the issue.
Uh, we have 18 years, I dunno how many months
or weeks that is, but we have an opportunity to seize the o
to seize that day, to begin to,
to make this spiritual influence.
And so it's going to require a commitment,
it's gonna require dedication.
And so, um,
Dr. Ross has done this all over the United States over 500
times, and he's going to lead us and a parent dedication.
If you're a single parent, if you're a grandparent,
if you don't have your kids here, uh,
you might find someone near you.
And, and let's spend this time in prayer too,
as these parents and, and these kids
are making commitments to one another.
Let's spend this time in prayer
and let's consecrate this church to becoming
a family Discipleship Church.
Dr. Rot, we complete us.